Since Uber invade our business it messed up
my life.
It is not a real bailout because we're not
asking for a penny.
We want big papa paying attention to us.
When Andrew Murstein hired pop music
star Nicki Minaj to headline his son Matt’s Bar Mitzvah,
it was an unusually conspicuous flaunting
of wealth
by one of New York City's leading taxi cab magnates.
Newsweek estimates that Minaj might have been
paid as much as half a million for the gig,
which entailed taking a personal photo with
every single prepubescent boy in attendance.
Andrew Murstein’s vast wealth derives from
a shrewd decision
that his grandpa Leon made 78 years ago.
In 1937, New York City issued what ultimately
amounted to 13,437 taxi medallions—
a special kind of license that conferred the
exclusive right to drive a cab in the Big Apple.
And Leon Murstein bought one for $10.
And then he bought several hundred more to
rent to other drivers.
Over the next 75 years price of each of those
medallions climbed from $10 to over a million dollars.
Ultimately all that value that’s built up
in the medallions comes out of passengers.
Josh Barro is a reporter at the The New York
Times, who covers the taxi industry.
Fares are higher than they otherwise would
be able to be
because you have to limit the number of people
using these taxis.
Over the years, the city tried periodically
to break the medallion cartel
to make life easier on the riding public,
but to no avail.
And then in May of 2011,
A new company rolled into town.
Welcome to Uber, a reliable ride is always
just minutes away.
Let's get one.
These are all the cars in your area and how
close they are.
For roughly two and a half years after Uber's
arrival, the taxi industry kept thriving.
In November 2013, Medallion Financial,
the publicly traded company that’s run by
Andrew Murstein
saw its share price hit a thirteen-year high.
But as more and more Uber cars took to the
streets the stock plummeted,
ultimately losing about half of its value.
The average number of trips taken in a cab
each day has fallen
and average farebox revenue has fallen.
The front of this taxi garage in Brooklyn
is jammed with parked cabs
because the company that runs it can’t find
enough drivers to hire.
They’d all rather go work for Uber.
It really is remarkable how these monopolies
that couldn’t be broken for decades
were broken so quickly
but I think it’s because of Uber moving
first
and saying, ‘we’re going show people how
this thing can be different,
and then we’ll have the fight over whether
we want that different thing or not.'
The Mursteins diversified out of the medallion
market long ago,
so they’ll end up rich no matter what happens.
But Gene Friedman, the city’s largest single
medallion holder
with an estimated 900 to his name,
is in deep trouble.
He has been sued by the attorney general for
ripping off drivers, flagged as a tax delinquent,
and a handful of the taxi garages he owns
have filed for bankruptcy protection.
In April, Friedman arranged a private meeting
with bankers,
medallion owners, and elected officials
to build support for a city bailout.
It’s a scream by a child for attention.
What you're doing is a scream?
That's correct?
From a child?
That's right.
This entire industry is a child?
No, you, that's not the-
We are absolute- we're all children of the
city.
We're all children of the city and the city
council, and of city hall.
His idea is that the government should step
in and offer a loan guarantee
so taxpayers would take the hit if medallion
prices were to keep tumbling.
It is not a real bailout because we’re not
asking for a penny here.
The problem is that if the city is guaranteeing
a repayment on a medallion loan
of a level exceeding the actual market price
of a taxi medallion,
and the city is going to be left on the hook
for millions and millions
and conceivably billions of dollars in lost
value on medallions.
Now what people like Gene would say is that
there's just a temporary disruption in this market
it's like 2008 after the financial crisis
and if the government just steps in and acts
as a guarantor, things will go back to normal.
That's not what's happening in the taxi space.
There's an actual solvency problem,
which is that the real value of a taxi medallion
has declined
because you can not generate as much profit
off of a taxi medallion as you used to be able to.
I used to work hard to get my dream to come
true in this country.
Sweet land of liberty, yes.
Alaa Khalil is an Egyptian immigrant
who spent years driving someone else's cab
about 90 hours a week.
In 1994, he’d finally saved enough to make
a down payment on his very own medallion,
which cost $178,000.
Between 94 and 2013, it was a very good life.
Since Uber invade our business, it messed
up my life.
Less fares to the airports, they took all
the airports.
And we used to see a lot of people in the
street
and now people are waiting in front of their
houses with the iphones
looking for the Uber to come, and they never
hail us anymore.
I'm in financial crush, I stopped payment
on all of my credit cards.
What if we lose this house, what about my
kids, where are they gonna live?
It's really hard.
Selling his medallion is no longer an option
because there’s no liquidity in the market.
Nobody even knows what a medallion would sell
for at this point
because in the past four months there hasn’t
been a single sale.
Just five bank foreclosures.
They're going to strip my medallion if I don't
pay like 2 months
they take your car, while you're sleeping
inside.
The people I would worry about are these individual
cab operators who own one medallion
who tied up their life savings in the medallion,
it's sad
and I think that there are, you know, there
are real people who got hurt here.
But again I would remember that the value
in those medallions was not free.
The value in those medallions came out of
elevated prices payed by consumers of taxi rides.
Alaa Khalil wouldn’t be in so much trouble
if he hadn’t treated his medallion like
a cash register over the years.
As its price soared, he took vacations, bought
an expensive house, and a luxury car.
Overall, he borrowed an additional $300,000
against its value.
I refinanced in the medallion too many times.
I mean, like three, four times.
Every time I need money, I needed money, I
go and pick up like 50 thousand, 40 thousand,
it was a lot of money in the medallion, now
I have nothing inside.
This is an argument for why you shouldn't
create a medallion system.
Not every city exposes small investors to
this business of making big bets in public policy
and we should try and build our economy not
around the government creating extra opportunities
for people to make those sorts of unwise investments.
Uber's been unequivocally good for taxi customers
and as even Khalil acknowledges, it's also
been good for many drivers.
It's a good opportunity for many immigrants,
yes, yes.
Because they don't, they're going to find
a new job and fast, and make money fast.
My nephew is an Uber, he's been here like
5 years now and he makes as much as I make now.
I'm happy for him, but I'm not happy for my
family.